It's difficult to imagine
anyone other
than Penn Badgley
playing the notorious
Joe Goldberg from YOU.
Hello... you.
His ability to switch
from a normal guy
to an unhinged serial killer
in the space of seconds
makes YOU the stellar hit
it has become.
Before he was Joe,
you may have known him
as Todd from Easy A
or perhaps Dan Humphrey
from Gossip Girl.
In honour of YOU season 3,
let's take a look at how
Penn Badgley arrived here
on his Road To Netflix.
Some of the most
striking parts of YOU
are, of course,
Joe Goldberg's narration...
I still believe in the one.
...so it may not
surprise you to hear
that Penn's
earlier acting work
was in voiceovers.
Believe it or not,
his first credits
were for voice work
in the video games
Mario Golf 64
and Mario Tennis 64
in 1999 and 2000,
doing all the tennis
and golf-playing
sound effects.
His early TV credits
included bit parts
on various shows
and sitcoms,
like this small part
playing a bully
on hit sitcom
Will & Grace...
-Can put your make-up in it.
-Hey, hey, hey!
Give him his backpack.
...and in 2002, here he is
alongside Amanda Bynes
in What I Like About You...
I think I actually saw
a flash of light!
That same year
he played the main role
of a 34-year-old
sent back in time
to re-live his childhood
in Do Over
Of all the times
to come back to,
why this one?
Tomorrow was the worst day
of my life!
Penn played
the 14-year-old version
of Jake,
blessed with adult wisdom
and a chance
to re-do the things
that went wrong for him
as a teen.
He went on to star
in more series
like The Mountain,
a drama set at a ski resort,
and 2006's
The Bedford Diaries,
where he starred
as college freshman, Owen.
That same year,
he had his movie debut
in the now
classic teen romcom
John Tucker Must Die,
he played
the younger brother
of the titular John Tucker,
a popular jock
dating three girls at once.
His character
becomes friends
with the girl they recruit
to try and ruin
the basketball star's life.
He will say
that it was my fault,
but I clearly said,
"Dear God, man,
you're on fire."
"Run for your life,"
On to 2007
and to one of Penn's
best known roles,
the one and only
Dan Humphrey in Gossip Girl.
Trash? Look, man,
I live in Brooklyn.
All right? Not the Ozarks.
No offence to the Ozarks.
It was actually a part
he initially turned down,
but took on after producers
struggled to find
anyone else suitable.
And it's just as well.
The role helped catapult
his career and earned him
16 Choice Awards
nominations.
If you somehow
haven't seen it,
the show follows the lives
of uber-rich kids
in Manhattan
who are closely watched
by a mysterious blogger
known only as gossip girl.
The show became a huge hit
and had a massive
cultural impact,
turning its stars
into huge celebrities
over the course
of its six seasons.
Penn's Dan,
a fish out of water
as the only Brooklynite
among
his super-rich classmates
was central to the story
as the so-called lonely boy
who moons over,
and eventually
gets a chance with,
Blake Lively's
Serena van der Woodsen.
Several chances, actually.
True, I may have peeked.
By the end
of the six seasons,
spoiler alert,
we find out Dan
was in fact gossip girl
all along.
You're no one
until you talk to them.
So, you came home,
told all of this to Jenny,
and that was the beginning
of gossip girl?
Could there be some echoes
of Joe Goldberg there?
Who could forget
2010's Easy A
in which Emma Stone
played Olive Pendergast,
a teen who tries to use
her school's
active rumour mill
in her favour,
with mixed results.
Penn starred as Olive's
love interest, Todd.
I, uh, I borrowed
my neighbour's mower
I came right over.
-That almost rhymed.
-I know.
I spent a minute on it.
He also, at one point,
appears
wearing a beaver costume.
In 2011's Margin Call,
Penn joined
an ensemble cast,
including Zachary Quinto
and Stanley Tucci,
a film based loosely
on the early stages
of the financial crash.
Fuck me!
Once this thing gets going
in the wrong direction
this is...
this is fucking huge.
Penn plays Seth,
a junior analyst
dragged into
a growing scandal
at a Wall Street
investment bank.
The following year,
he took on the role
of musician Jeff Buckley,
in
Greetings from Tim Buckley,
a film exploring
Buckley's relationship
with his father's legacy,
culminating with a concert
where he performed
his songs.
It's like all these people
playing tribute to Tim.
He spent his entire life
abandoning
the people we love,
so, like,
what am I doing here?
With that performance
in mind,
it's probably
no surprise to hear
Penn also has
a music career,
fronting four-piece
Indie pop band MOTHXR.
He and three of his friends
formed the band in 2013,
recording
their first five songs
in a bungalow in LA
over eight days.
They released
their debut album Centerfold
in 2016.
That brings us to 2018
and Penn's latest
and most terrifying role.
-And you're Joe...
-Goldberg.
On the face of it,
he's a mild-mannered
and charming
book store manager.
In reality, he's a stalker
and a serial killer,
twisting the tropes
of romantic films
to fit his unhinged
behaviour towards women.
When he meets
Guinevere Beck,
he slowly insinuates himself
into her life,
stealing her phone,
stalking her around campus
and killing
her sort of boyfriend.
I would do anything for you.
How many guys are willing
to do anything
for the person they love?
Honestly, Beck,
you're lucky to have me.
This was another role
he almost didn't take on,
worrying
about the nature of it.
But, in the end,
he was convinced
by the script
and the social commentary
the series would provide.
Then, there's the link
between this role
and the other
he's best known for.
Dan Humphrey
literally wrote himself
into Serena's life
and viewers have definitely
seen the connection
between the two.
Penn himself seems to agree,
telling the New Yorker:
"It's the same role,
it's just Joe has blood
dripping down his face."
He's also been very quick
to remind people
thirsting over Joe Goldberg
that this guy
is a literal serial killer.
YOU became a worldwide hit
after it dropped on Netflix,
returning
for two more seasons.
In the latest,
Joe is a father in suburbia
with his equally
unhinged wife, Love.
I think we need to go
to couple's therapy.
But to find out
what happens there,
you'll have to catch
series 3
now streaming on Netflix.